how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Marvel is trying to do everything that
they possibly can to try and keep
everything about Avengers endgame a
secret rightfully so because Avengers in
game is supposed to be Marvel's biggest
movie of all time to date with a runtime
that is rumored to be three hours and
two minutes and the Russo brothers and
Marvel has gone to great lengths to make
sure no spoilers get out including
giving some of the actors partial
scripts giving some of them fake scripts
and of course altering some scenes in
the trailers but sometimes leaks and
spoilers come from odd places such as
today's leak comes from Sergio Zurita
who does the voiceover for Rocket
Raccoon in Spanish and with a recent
interview with MVS he let out some
spoilers so if you don't want anything
spoiled for Avengers in game here's your
official spoiler alert
also if you're new to my channel make
sure you subscribe I'm doing a new
giveaway giving away five imax tickets
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so this was sent to me by my
buddy I'm a film editor who is a film
editor in the industry works a lot with
IMAX and in does interview Sergio talks
about some deaths in the interview he
says I can tell you that the movie takes
you from laughter to tears
a key character dies I cannot say more
it's more I do not know if I already
said more obviously fans have speculated
for a long time that somebody's going to
die in this movie mainly pointing to
Captain America or Iron Man but as
Sergio continues to talk about Rockets
emotional changes in Avengers in game it
could be somebody different he goes on
to say the movie looks intense
good rocket is in another state of mind
rocket is always angry and throwing a
bullet and now rocket is brooding
moreover there is a time when rocket is
so sad that he does not care to be told
in certain ways that it bothers him that
they always tell him this obviously
makes perfect sense rocket lost
everybody his whole family except for
nebula who he really wasn't close with
to begin with so the fact that he's just
going around and shooting gung-ho and
doesn't care about what anybody says to
him makes perfect sense and fits right
along with how rocket behaves
however rocket did get kind of close to
Thor in Avenger
infinity war okay time to be the captain
so dead brother huh and there is a part
in the interview where Sergio says that
there are irreversible consequences with
Thor he says there are irreversible
things very interesting very interesting
what happens with Thor and at the end he
went on to say more but then he stopped
himself saying there's a dialogue
between rocket and no I think I cannot
say that any more
so who could this person be that rocket
is talking about could it be
Thor after all Chris Hemsworth's
contract is up and there have been
rumors that he's not going to renew it
but we have also learned that the hulk
and rocket will become good friends and
Avengers in game as well and as the same
with Chris Hemsworth Mark Ruffalo's
contract is up as well and we don't know
if he's going to renew it and let's not
forget we see rocket on the shoulder of
rody in the trailers and although I do
love rody I'm not sure his death would
be considered a major death rody is
definitely a major character but when I
hear major death I think one of the
original six Avengers and Sergio was
talking about the irreversible
consequences that Thor will have to face
an Avengers end game rocket and Thor
went on a mission together in Avengers
infinity war and it seems like that's
going to happen again in Avengers
endgame after all in the scene with all
of the Avengers walking in the
headquarters wearing the white suits
rockin and Thor are not there so it's
most likely they went somewhere together
on a mission so Sergio has confirmed
that there will be a major death in the
movie could this be Thor or could it be
somebody else let me know what you all
think in the comments down below I think
as most of you know Thor is my personal
favorite so I really hope it's not four
but let me know what you think about
what Sergio said in this interview and
let me know who you think is going to
die in Avengers end game and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to marvel and Avengers in-game as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]
you